bienvenue à tous pareils tacler le mag
c'est votre magazine sur toute
l'actualité du territoire cette fois ci
on vous emmène à saint quentin en
yvelines où se sont déroulés les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste c'était juste derrière moi au
vélodrome nationale cette médaille pour
la france dont 5 en or à succès sportif
et populaire saint quentin en yvelines
c'est aussi son théâtre nous avons
rencontré son tout nouveau directeur
lionel masse et à vous découvrirez aussi
safran tech nous le centre de recherche
et de technologie du groupe il y a tout
juste d'être inaugurée sur le plateau de
saclay à suivre les précisions de son
directeur stéphane caine paris saclay à
pôle d'excellence qui veut se faire
connaître d'où sa participation à
tech'innove le rendez vous mihoubi de
l'innovation paris saclay a présenté ses
cinq clusters industriels dans des
secteurs stratégiques
enfin toute l'actualité en bref et en
images c'est dans l'agenda à la fin de
cette émission
saint quentin en yvelines à la une des
médias du monde entier le vélodrome
nationale a accueilli les championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste à succès
sportif pour la france cette médaille de
remporter dont cinq en or un succès
populaire aussi toutes les places ont
été vendues notre équipe était sur place
bien sûr
depuis notre arrivée à saint quentin en
yvelines et bien les partenaires
viennent à la fédération il envoie les
deux fédérations qui a la crédibilité
qui a des résultats sportifs on l'a vu
cinq médailles d'or l'année dernière
dans l'ensemble des disciplines
olympiques en élite et trois sur sur
piste une en vtt une sur route ça veut
dire que c'est une fédération parmi les
fédérations française avec celle sans
doute de natation on est celle où il ya
le plus d'espoirs olympique donc
j'espère que c'est de nature à attirer
des partenaires qui a fait en sorte que
nos athlètes soient mieux reconnus et
aussi mieux indemnisés et mieux rémunéré
on a tous intérêt à ce qu'on ait des
magnifiques événement dans notre foi
dans notre sport les gens s'y trompe pas
tout le monde veut venir aux
championnats du monde
tous les présents fédérations nationales
étrangères sont là il n'y a jamais eu
autant de présidents de fédérations
étrangères donc que ça veut dire qu'on
attire il ya un engouement autour de
céder autour de ces chômeurs du monde
sur piste qui valent largement au delà
de la compétition en elle-même mais qui
montre les langues globalement de notre
fédération
c'est un territoire de sport je crois
que c'est un territoire qu'ils
l'approuvaient deux fédérations majeures
le cyclisme et le golfe ayant leur siège
ici ayant leur lieu de pratiquer le golf
national et le vélodrome national
vincent fait forcément un territoire qui
rayonne à l'international et qui est
prêt pour cette belle aventure
normalement pour un euro investi c'est
entre 3 et 6 euros de retombées
économiques directes pour le territoire
outre on va dire tout l'image que dégage
de territoire et donc ça c'est favorable
aussi à l'implantation de nouvelles
entreprises il ya un élan qui est donné
et c'est aussi je pense une vraie fierté
pour les habitants de l'île de france
pour les yvelinois et pour les signé mon
teint aussi particulièrement ici
l'idée c'est que notamment sur le bmx
sur le vtt et sur le cyclisme sur piste
et gars tous puissent se passer à saint
quentin en yvelines dont on voit bien à
l'investissement qui a eu en faveur du
cyclisme et qui doit pouvoir trouver via
son aboutissement dans l'aventuré
olympique paris 2024
voilà pour les amateurs de la petite
reine mais saint quentin en yvelines
c'est aussi une vie culturelle riche
avec son théâtre et son tout nouveau
directeur lionel masse et à il propose
une programmation à l'image de paris
saclay pluridisciplinaire est ouverte
sur le territoire avec notamment la mise
en place des rencontres in cité il nous
en dit plus
et qui avait extrêmement intéressant
avec la scène nationale de 50 ans c'est
d'une part ce lieu lui même et de
travail qui est fait mais c'est
également son positionnement sur un
double territoire le territoire de
l'agglomération mais également le
territoire paris saclay donc ça se
conjugue aussi deux envies l'envi d'une
part de continuer à renforcer ses liens
artistiques avec un territoire le
territoire de l'agglomération mais
également de développer toute une partie
du projet des partenariats avec un des
acteurs essentiels de 7 200 ouest de
l'île de france qui est bien entendu le
cluster paris saclay
dans ce que nous souhaitons mettre en
oeuvre il y a que j'ai intitulé les
rencontres une cité des rencontres-i
cité qu'est ce que c'est c'est chaque
saison réfléchir à une thématique une
thématique précise et cette thématique
et la traiter avec plusieurs entrées des
entrées qui sont artistique ça c'est
nécessaire c'est indispensable parce que
c'est une scène nationale c'est une
scène qu'est consacré à la mais comment
est-ce qu'on peut arriver à proposer
d'autres entrées des entrées qui serait
scientifique bilan que technologique des
entrées qui relèveraient la sociologie
de l'histoire de la philosophie donc
comment mettre tous ces acteurs ensemble
au service des thématiques et comment la
traiter de façon la plus globale la plus
contradictoires aussi possible
on peut conjuguer art et science on peut
conjuguer art et technologie ce sont des
sujets un tout petit peu différent mais
en tout cas je pense qu'il ya des
approches communes et ses approches
communes c'est la créativité que l'on
travaille dans des laboratoires de
fabrication que l'on travaille sur un
plateau théâtre dans tous les camps
doivent faire appel à une créativité à
une vraie liberté donc je pense qu'il ya
des rapprochements qui sont très claires
à faire entre ces méthodologies de
travail et peut-être même des processus
de travail qui sont communs et qui trop
souvent s'ignorent quoique je pense que
pour les artistes sur une trentaine ou
une quarantaine d'années qui sont nés
avec ses réflexions d'un qui sont
inscrits dans le monde et dans dans les
évolutions technologiques ces questions
tout à fait naturel
parmi les temps forts de la rentrée
l'inauguration de safran tech nouveau
pôle d'excellence de votre territoire ce
site sera le fer de lance de la
recherche de l'innovation du groupe
safran il accueillera 300 chercheurs et
ingénieurs des hommes et des femmes
venus de tous horizons
safran pareil sur la diversité et
l'excellence scientifique a lieu
inauguré par la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enseignement supérieur
geneviève fioraso
le projet paris saclay est d'ores et
déjà structuré autour de nombreuses
institutions d'enseignement supérieur et
de recherche et le nouveau centre de
safran via renforcer la composante
entrepreneuriat les industriels de ce
plateau aux côtés de sociétés comme
dassault systèmes un liquide à laquelle
du cents ou encore thales mais aussi aux
côtés de pépinière de start up qu'il
sera tout à fait important de développer
encore davantage
on a cherché à avoir un équilibre on
veut des gens tous les horizons parce
qu'on pense que au delà d'excellence
scientifique le fait d'avoir de la
diversité de cultures est important donc
on cherche à avoir un équilibre entre
des gens qui viennent de safran et puis
des gens qui viennent de la recherche ou
d'autres industries et que nous apporte
un regard extérieur et des connaissances
plus connectés avec la recherche
scientifique aujourd'hui on a un bon
équilibre on a un peu plus de 60% gens
qui viennent de l'extérieur qui viennent
aux industries mais beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines universitaires ou qui sortent
de terre dans les meilleurs labo on
voulait avoir des gens de haut niveau
donc on voulait avoir beaucoup de gens
au niveau doctorat qui est approfondi
leurs connaissances à peu près deux
tiers on a des doctorants aussi dans une
vingtaine et on essaiera de monter
jusqu'à une quarantaine une vingtaine de
pourcents de gens qui sont soit étranger
soit qu'ils ont la double nationalité
donc on a un creuset mais ce qui est
important pour nous c'est la diversité
et de l'excellence scientifique
on a des partenariats historiques et
qu'on a qu'on a développés à l'occasion
de notre implantation avec le ca on a
tout un tas d'école avec qui on a des
partenariats historiques on veut
renforcer les liens avec la formation je
pense qu'on peut attirer plus
d'étudiants on peut valoriser les
formations par la recherche et en
bénéficier on est dans les meilleures
conditions pour le faire
l'infrastructure pourrait être encore un
peu améliorée sur le niveau des
transports mais c'est vraiment ça qui
nous attire
on va travailler sur sur trois axes de
recherche un axe sur plutôt sur les
systèmes sont à des systèmes et
technologies où on va travailler sur la
compréhension de l'énergétique des
avions des avions plus électrique donc
de leur architecture architecture de nos
clients on a un deuxième acte qui est
sur les matériaux et composants on
travaille sur tous les matériaux dont on
a besoin pour la propulsion et l'avion
plus électrique et puis on travaille sur
les composants électroniques tout ce qui
va nous permettre de disposer dans nos
systèmes de nouvelles données
d'exploiter les nouveaux services pour
nos clients enfin le dernier axe c'est
sur les technologies du numérique avec
la modélisation la simulation pour
modéliser nos produits et puis un axe
sur le traitement du signal et
d'information encore pour améliorer la
performance et offrir de nouveaux
services à nos clients
être un pôle d'excellence c'est bien le
faire savoir c'est encore mieux d'où la
présence de paris saclay à tech'innove
le rendez-vous be to be de l'innovation
l'occasion de présenter les cinq grands
clusters de paris saclay et de faire un
zoom sur trois d'entre eux sanofi
alcatel et alstom j'ai eus ont accepté
de participer à une table ronde tout de
suite les précisions de patrick chêne
directeur du développement économique de
l'établissement public paris saclay
by saclay c'est un pour cent de la
population française 650 mille habitants
et 15% de la recherche publique
académique mais aussi 15% de la r&d
industrielle de la france donc c'est une
hyper concentration une très forte
spécialisation et pour la rendre
compréhensible parce que c'est au coeur
de ce qu'est le projet paris saclay avec
la constitution de l'université
il nous a paru intéressant de proposer
une lecture en cinq clusters industriels
qui sont je dirais par ordre
d'apparition
aérospatiale défense sécurité mobilité
automobile
thijs et technologies de l'information
et la communication santé
et l'énergie climat avec un accent
particulier sur la gestion intelligente
de l'énergie ce qu'on appelle aussi les
smart grid mais les réseaux d échange de
chaleur et les technologies du bâtiment
en matière d'énergie également on a
proposé à trois industriels qui font
partie de 3 des secteurs de nous
rejoindre pour une table ronde pendant
tech'innove 2015 et on a choisi le
secteur de la santé nhs et lycées et de
l'énergie parce que ce sont trois
secteurs sur lequel aujourd'hui il ya
des enjeux très fort dans la compétition
mondiale entre clusters et écosystème
d'innovation il nous a semblé
particulièrement intéressant de mettre
en avant les forces de paris saclay dans
ces différents domaines avec le
témoignage de sanofi pour le secteur à
la santé celui d'alcatel pour les
technologies de l'information et la
communication et d'alstom dit
pour l'énergie
cette manifestation se déroule ici à
orly c'est d'un neuvième édition
l'intérêt c'est réunir sur ce même
endroit plus d'une centaine de grands
comptes d'honneur dans plus d'une
centaine de laboratoires qui permettent
donc d'accéder à ces pme leur permette
d'accéder à de la recherche et du
développement
une grande partie en fait du tissu de la
bo particuliers privés ou publics sont
situées sur le territoire de paris
saclay un gain bon nombre également de
start up se trouve sur les territoires
ddt europ'essonne la caps qui sont
générateurs à travers les liens qu'ils
ont avec les universités grandes écoles
générateur de projets porteurs de projet
intéressés par le fait de trouver ici
effectivement soit des sources de
financement soit des courants d'affaires
qui leur permettront de se développer
et maintenant compromis notre agenda
tous les événements à ne pas rater dans
les semaines qui viennent réservez déjà
votre 5 mars pour la journée
entrepreneuriat étudiant paris saclay ça
se passe al'instar paristech 150
étudiants entrepreneurs de l'université
paris saclay y participent laissez-vous
convaincre par leur projet et qui fait
vous allez peut-être y participer autre
date à inscrire celle du 14 mars avec la
journée des masters de l'université
paris saclay c'est toujours à leinster
paristech venez découvrir l'offre de
formation en master ainsi que les écoles
doctorales une offre toujours aussi
diversifiée et simplifie enfin sachez
que l'établissement public paris saclay
organisent des comités de suivi de
chantier sur les quartiers de l'école
polytechnique et du monde ce sera les 16
et 17 mars pour plus d'informations
seule adresse au pps point fr paris sac
et le mac c'est déjà terminé on se
retrouve très vite pour faire un point
sur toute l'actualité de votre
territoire d'ici là vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site le
pps point fr a très vite
e